no mucho ha cambiado durante la última
década en este barrio de catherine esta
localidad cerca de la frontera con
argelia fue uno de los epicentros de la
revolución tunecina aquí fueron
asesinados varios manifestantes y para
esta familia que perdió un hijo amargura
no se va
al comienzo en enero no se escucharon y
estudiaron nuestro caso pero luego se
olvidó y fueron nuestros hijos los que
trajeron la libertad a este país la
gente está orgullosa de ellos pero sus
padres a ellos los hicieron a un lado se
lo debemos a nuestros hijos darles
justicia
mi hijo mohamed murió hace 10 años pero
para mí se siente como si hubiera sido
ayer estas calles pueden ser nuevas pero
muchos de los problemas estructurales
tras esa expresión de ira de 2011
permanecen las ong aseguran que nunca se
materializó una esperada lucha contra la
corrupción pero para abbas en sage
algunas cosas mejoraron
hoy hay cosas positivas como la libertad
de expresión la libertad para hacer
campañas y formar asociaciones pero
catherine sigue siendo uno de los
pueblos más pobres y marginales y eso es
responsabilidad de la sucesión de
gobiernos
a 50 km de este pueblo una carretera nos
lleva a esta aislada localidad desde la
revolución estas montañas han sido
escenario de violencia entre las fuerzas
de seguridad y grupos yihadistas en
diciembre el sobrino de mustafa fue
asesinado los extremistas
sospechaban que este joven pastor era un
informante naval este era nuestro hogar
y luego los terroristas vinieron y lo
tomaron y esta es la casa de mi hermano
miren tan siquiera tiene electricidad
miren cómo vive mi madre mi hija no
tiene dónde dormir
catherine tiene muchos mártires de la
revolución y hay hambre en el campo diez
años después de la revolución los más
vulnerables aquí se enfrentan a una
nueva amenaza la pandemia de covite 19
las restricciones supone que mustafá ya
no puede dar entretenimiento en las
bodas así que por ahora su música es más
que nunca una herramienta de placer pero
no para ganarse la vida